thank you madam Speaker I rise today to
address the great American bathroom
controversy this is a picture on my
right of someone who may or may not be
recognizable to many Americans today
I'll say her name the name may be more
recognizable to some her name is
Christine Jorgensen Christine Jorgensen
was born in 1926 she grew up in the
Bronx like I did she went to high school
at Christopher Columbus High School
which was near the public housing where
I grew up in the Bronx fact my father
taught history at Christopher Columbus
High School I don't know whether he
taught Christine or not but it is
possible in 1945
Christine was drafted and served in the
US military now that may be a puzzle for
some of you listening to me right now
he'll say I didn't realize that women
were drafted in the 1940s well at that
time Christine's name was George George
Jorgensen that's name she was born with
she was in fact on her birth certificate
male something that she struggled with
greatly all through the time that she
was growing up being a male something
that she struggled with being in the
military and then after leaving military
service in 1951 she heard about the
possibility of changing her gender so
she went to Denmark and underwent three
or more surgeries plus a very
substantial amount of estrogen
treatments came back the United States
and then forever it thereafter after
1953 was known as Christine Jorgensen
Christine Jorgensen was out she was well
known in America as someone who was
transgendered I knew about her story
when I was growing up in the 60s and 70s
she made no effort to hide
and feel any shame about it in fact she
was proud of the fact that you've been
able to take advantage of what medicine
had to offer and live the life that she
felt she would have been able to live
from the beginning if she'd had the
proper gender she had degrees some
degree of fame Republican vice president
Spiro Agnew referred to her once in a
speech to mock one of his political
opponents and she performed both as a
singer and as an actress all through the
50s through the entire 1960s and well
into the 1970s she was the most famous
if you will
transgendered person in America probably
to this day now I have to tell you I
don't know exactly where she went when
she had to go I don't know exactly
whether she went into a men's room or a
lady's room but here's the interesting
thing even though this was something new
Under the Sun even though America I'd
never had to address this issue before
no one ever even bothered to ask I don't
remember anybody saying Christine
Jorgensen she ought to go to the men's
room she was born a male or for that
matter Christine Jorgensen she
identifies as a female she should go to
the ladies room isn't it odd that
America in the 1950s seems to show seems
to shown a lot more maturity than
America showing today with our great
bathroom controversy right now where the
cisgendered people of America try to
dictate to the transgendered people of
America where they can go to the
bathroom or at least frankly the more
bigoted among us now we had a law passed
recently in North Carolina I say it's
going to go out on a limb and say that
it passed almost exclusively with
cisgendered Republican votes in which
they tried to dictate which bathroom
Christine Jorgensen would have to go to
you're alive today and had to relieve
herself and amazing enough they actually
decided in their wisdom that Christine
Jorgensen if she were alive today like
all of her transgendered brothers and
sisters Christine Jorgensen would have
to go to the room the bathroom that she
didn't identify as but instead the
bathroom that was on her birth
certificate now this is a particular
ironic
there was one form of discrimination of
Christine Jorgensen did actually face
during her lifetime she's not allowed to
get married he's not allowed to get
married to a man because her birth
certificate said she was a male and she
was not issued a marriage license on
account of the fact that a male is
trying to marry a male well my goodness
here in America just in the past 12
months or so we finally managed to solve
that problem and Christine Jorgensen
could get married today to her her lover
now we have a whole new problem now
thanks to Republicans bigots in North
Carolina we have a law that would
require Christine Jorgensen to go to the
men's room think about that think about
that in fact the natural consequence of
that law is what I'm about to show you
right here that
so you folks in North Carolina
who are obsessed with where the
transgendered go to the bathroom this is
the result you've come up with to have
people who self-identify as women people
look like women people who act like
women they somehow are being driven into
the men's room and the same thing is
true with transgendered who identify as
men you're going to force people who
look like men act like men identifies
men you're going to force them into the
ladies room my god what's wrong with you
that doesn't make any sense at all
now let me tell you something if I had
been back in the day growing up in New
York and Christine Jorgensen happened to
walk into the men's room never happened
but let's say it did I would have
thought that's odd but I want to set a
word about it I wouldn't have gone over
terms said to her excuse me I don't
think you're supposed to be here on the
contrary I would have made an
appropriate mental note assume that she
probably found herself in the wrong
men's room and I would have let it go I
would not have felt any fear I would not
have felt any fate Rideau felt anything
that would indicate to me that somehow I
should discriminate against this person
nevertheless I would have thought it was
odd what this law does is guarantee that
experience or worse to have people who
identify and look and dress and act like
women forced to go into a men's room to
have people identify and look and act
and dress as men forced to go into a
ladies room are you nuts
listen and I have heard that the
Republican Party is the party of small
government I've also heard that on the
issue of abortion party of small
government wants government's small
enough to fit into a woman's uterus
now it turns out the party's small
government wants governments small
enough to fit underneath the toilet seat
can't we all be adults about this can we
all be adults about this the way we were
in the 1960s and 70s and 80s do we
really need a new law on this subject
much less a stupid law a bad law a
ridiculous law now you know I understand
that it's possible even when the absence
of this law that there might be some
conceivable problems about this kind of
situation I'm not sure exactly what they
are I'm pretty sure that if everybody
exactly acted as an adult we get beyond
them without having to litigate over it
and I'm wondering how do you even
enforce the law like this what are we
going to do have to give saliva samples
every time you want to go to the
bathroom to see what gender we were born
with my goodness bear in mind there's a
law against loitering there's law
against wide stances at a bathroom a
Republican senator learned that a few
years ago there's a law against
disorderly conduct
there's a law against voyeurism there's
a law against indecent exposure in fact
in a really bad situation there are laws
against assault and even rape so why do
we need a law to dictate that people who
identify as men have to go to the ladies
room and people identify as ladies have
to go to the men's room
you know we had laws like that once we
used to say that we didn't want white
people that have to be uncomfortable
going to the bathroom with black people
I represent part of the state of Florida
I can remember that when we had laws
like that and then somehow or other we
pull ourselves together we realized how
ridiculous that was well how is this any
different thank goodness the Attorney
General recognizes that it's not people
who are assist gendered have no right to
dictate where people who are
transgendered urinate any more than
people who are white had the right to
dictate where people are black do it
that's not America let's show some
since now if we did actually want to
deal with real problems we could deal
with this one a little boy and a little
girl both looking into their diapers and
the caption is oh that explains the
difference in our wages now if we want
to talk about gender in America in the
early 21st century we could start with
that why is it that women still make
only 79 cents for every dollar that a
man makes in countless occupations and
professions even today why is that if
you want to get to the heart of what's
really going on between the sexes in
America today why don't we do something
to address that problem and if we want
to be more dramatic about it let's
remember the fact that in America today
91 percent of the victims of rape are
women could we take our legislative
energy and possibly apply it toward
dealing with that problem which actually
is a problem that affects countless
women across the country
let's not protect them from having the
or the same bathroom as a transgendered
person by insisting that people look and
act and identify as men go to the
bathroom with them let's instead try to
pass wise laws that would equalize pay
between men and women oh and if we
possibly could reduce the incidence the
terrible incidence of rape but getting
back to this North Carolina law there is
a deep legal principle that this law of
fed's defends me it fends a lot of
people with a good conscience and that
deep legal principle is this it goes by
four letters M Y o B that's an even
higher law than the law that was
asked by the North Carolina legislature
my Obie mind your own business
I yield back the gentleman yields back